on t'as demandé de sélectionner que les
moments les plus drôles dans la méthode
et dans d'autres choses que tu as fait à
la télé et on va revenir sur un extrait
de la méthode cauet tu avais des armes
était incroyable et avait reçu will
smith
tu l'as mis à l'amendé au bras de fer ce
qui a donné une séquence énorme regarde
formidable tu sais qu'une petite chemise
tu es venu depuis il a fait du sport
quand il a fait du sport il est mis ses
muscles et vas-y on voit ces martyrs à
lés écoute moi ça me ferait mal de serre
cet homme
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
dès lors et non on me disait vas-y
doucement je lui ben vas-y doucement tu
fais pas tous les jours que tu as raison
mais j'attends vraiment gagner alors on
a une autre séquence que tu as voulu
revoir aussi culte c'était dans ton
émission bienvenue chez cauet sur nrj 12
elodie gossuin c'était fait hypnotisé
par messmer et elodie elle vit le truc à
100% le faisait à mon signal au compte
de 3 vous allez vous imaginez assise
dans une montagne russe
1 2 3 essayez vous prenez le petit bar
de temps à vous qui vient de se blesser
et on commence à monter on monte nous
aident à cette vocation montrent au
monde plus en plus elle est vue de plus
en plus forte au niveau parce que nous
faisons plus ample est encore de plus en
plus haut
nous sommes maintenant au dessus de ces
niveaux attention ces marchés
[Applaudissements]
mais on embrasse qui il est très très
fort mais merlus fait de gros bisous est
ce assez
c'est normal et c'est pas truqué c'est
pas truqué d'art je vous assure pas ce
que je suis vraiment avant elle était
pas au courant et je suis réjouis
d'avoir vraiment elle a joué le jeu à
fond c'est alors la séquence préférée
c'est dans ça se discute on découvre la
meuf la plus angoissante de la terre
elle est très très angoissée le mec
rentrent du boulot et on lui
souhaiterait presque de ne plus jamais
rentré c'est la séquence que tu as
choisi quoi c'est la séquence de le gars
de gars n'a pas le pouvoir une seconde à
la maison était peut-être vu cette
séquence oui moi je peux voir sa maman
faut regarder rôle à vue au foot non
quand il est au foot
bon il regarde là c'est un autre moment
on regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je me ferais
bouffer tout seul
eh ben il suffit d'envoyer dix minutes
un quart de rang record alors que ce
soit me dis que ce soit le soir
alors on commence à monter dans les
tours c'était tu sais que c'est moi qui
décide cette mini série
comme bagage difficile quand on écoute
de l'effort c'est dur à dire